foreign
omics
m-e-r-o genomics
recently put out a three-part series on
the potential for the inoculated to shed
Spike protein
in summary he discusses exosomes
particles exhaled in breath and how they
can transmit both antibodies from
natural infection and Spike proteins
from inoculation
one study he cites mentions that
exosomes coated in Spike protein once
inhaled can diminish antibody response
when exosomes are accompanied by actual
SARS cov2
any thoughts
so actually this a my doubt I haven't
seen like all we're working on is this
the thumbnail conjecture yeah which is a
nicely described
um again the obstacle with all of these
shedding things
is
the amount that is shed is presumably
tiny compared to the amount that the
person who is sick or vaccinated has on
board the effect should be tiny and to
the extent that we are discussing the
consequences of shedding
it is disproportionate and that
disproportionality requires something
you know viruses are this way right you
can shed a small number of particles and
give somebody a full-blown infection why
because those particles copy themselves
and so the small number of particles
that they picked up from you is not the
number of particles that they have they
need to be replicators for for that part
that story to work requires that they're
replicators right which is why I've said
a prion mechanism would be a basically a
contagious misfolding yeah something
that's a possibility I will say I don't
think that the limit of shedding
is Spike protein
I think the mrnas the hyper stabilized
mrnas are
well if they're being shed then they are
potential replicators
yeah they
I mean they're designed to be in their
original formulation
themselves but want to move into and
yeah I don't know they've been
stabilized and we've seen some evidence
that they can uh work their way back
into DNA but again none of these things
should be happening at a high enough
rate yeah for detectable phenomena to
happen so there's something mysterious
going on but the the conjecture here
that or or maybe it is a description of
a result that we cannot validate is that
the presence of Spike protein in the
exhaled water droplets
is
an obstacle to the immunity either
vaccine-induced or natural immunity to
SARS cov2 this matters a lot now I don't
know that the amount that is exhaled by
anybody is enough to substantially
affect how much immunity there is but
the mechanism is obvious
the you inhale the spike protein
a certain number of the antibodies that
would ordinarily bond to the viral
particles will bond to these Spike
proteins that aren't connected to
anything and they will be busy right
it's like you know cops detained giving
traffic tickets when there's a bank
robbery or something or like a riot
right if
the cops are detained by a natural
disaster right it means that there are
fewer cops to enforce regular laws and
so people will break them
um
the
I didn't suggest that for exhaled Spike
protein but I certainly did suggest that
for the vaccinating of people who had
natural immunity
one of the reasons not to do that is
that you will decrease the effectiveness
of that natural immunity by detaining
obvious antibodies and presumably T
cells that are targeted at actual SARS
cov2
as they are involved in fighting
um
cells that have that objection would
weaken the longer it had been since you
had coveted
right the more time your immune system
had already had to act on building your
natural immunity
the less risk of detaining your immune
system on one thing when it should be
doing the other thing Applause no I
don't think so I think that if you have
natural immunity that is still effective
at some level
then sending it
articles or things that will create
particles that will call its attention
is always bad
to the extent that your natural immunity
prevents you from coming down with cases
of SARS cov2 that you would otherwise
but it's not but if it's or if you've
already got immunity if you've already
got your natural immunity the risk isn't
that those things are being detained
when what they should be doing is
building your natural immunity no no
it's not a question of building your
natural Community they should be
surveilling your system so that if SARS
cov2 shows up okay that it doesn't get
through okay
if you occupy them with phonies
um some some new some new covet could
show up and and uh you might be less
likely to find it or it would take
longer and then you might get sicker
yeah yeah you could get sick where you
wouldn't otherwise get which is why the
where they treated people who
had been vaccinated but hadn't had two
weeks of time to develop a full response
or treated as unvaccinated when in fact
the point is what's the net effect well
you may have depressed their immunity
for two weeks before you got any
benefits right so no I thought you were
actually gonna that's for sure but we
heard several stories
of um and I never saw it in any news
reports but we heard several anecdotal
stories of people who had been sick
enough with covid or with something else
that they had been hospitalized
um but it's the Sick Enough with covid
part of this that that is just enraging
and that upon being well enough to go
home they were told over and over and
over again now you need to get
vaccinated yeah like no stop that yeah
like let your body do what it needs to
do at least first even if you know even
if safe and effective let your body do
what it needs to do first yeah
vaccinating people with a novel platform
even if safe and effective was my was my
like even absent all of the like very
real concerns uh that are you know even
even more real and bigger than we ever
thought
um still you know you don't oh you're
finally well enough to go home let's
suppress your natural immune response
here
bye yeah see you later soon sooner
rather than later maybe
oh here there's an update uh this is
going to be from uh something that
happened in our private q a last week
we heard at the very end about
um a woman whose friend's son had ended
up in the ICU with a heart event and was
doing very very poorly
um update my friend's son made it he was
in the ICU for four days but he is on
his way home tomorrow he was diagnosed
with myocarditis brought on by rheumatic
fever from a strep infection weird since
Rheumatic fevers are very rare in the
developed world thank you for all your
thoughts P.S he did have the Pfizer
booster in February
so glad he made it yeah
absolutely so glad
[Music]